mayor george
what are you doing here surprise grey's
anatomy brought back
another beloved character on thursday
night's episode
tr knight aka george o'malley how did
you get older
sand isn't real ocean isn't real body
it's not real maybe it's just more
peaceful for you to imagine me older
i sound like a fortune cookie
this marks the second big return on
season 17.
of course patrick dempsey was the first
[Music]
these returns all happen as part of
meredith's coven 19 dreams
do i choose do i get to decide
if i go back i don't know i didn't
i would have stayed if i could have
it's different for everyone though
before the season premiered actor jake
borelli told et it was likely one of the
docs would contract coronavirus
do any of the characters contract covid
19 is that part of the story
you know what covett is a really really
hard world and i think it's going to be
interesting to see how the doctors deal
with covet in all
respects but hospitals have been um
the hardest hit and um i think it's
going to be
sort of interesting to see into the
lives of all these doctors
tiaran shared behind the scenes pics of
his return and praised ellen pompeo on
instagram quote ellen is the kind of
actor i'm endlessly grateful to act with
she's the embodiment of truth george and
meredith love each other for sure but i
don't think he can hold a candle to the
love i have
for ellen i was so mad at you
well for leaving you you're choosing
someone over yourself
i didn't know i was gonna die
do you regret it
does that matter you'd have done the
same thing isn't that why you're here
[Music]
yeah i guess tr initially left the show
in 2009
after five seasons his character was
killed off after being hit by a bus
in a bid to save a woman's life
[Music]
o'malley got hit by a bus
you were all cracking up at my funeral
what what no
it that made me happy
i was devastated and then
i was okay some grief is
it's heavier than other grief sometimes
it moves through you and sometimes
it just gets stuck fans are speculating
all these returns could be a sign that
this
is the final season of the hit abc
series
yes we're starting to think about how
you would end a show this
iconic um how do you end it ellen pompeo
recently said that this season
could very well be the last season of
grey's anatomy
were you shocked by those comments at
all
i mean great grace has been on for 17
years now and i think there's
always this sort of like is it gonna
keep going can it keep
reinventing itself can it keep being
creative and
i know the answer to be yes and so um
my huge hope as a fan of the show is
that we do another 17 seasons
do you think that ellen wants
to leave the show do you think she wants
to do another 17
seasons just like i have no idea i don't
know
i think she's having a blast i think
she's been having a blast
and we're a family after seeing patrick
and tr return
fans are hoping to see more stars from
gray's past it's something kevin mckid
who plays owen hunt
and also directs on the show teased in
an interview with e.t
last month what you saw last week that
everybody freaked out about is just a
tiny
it's like the tip of the iceberg of
what's to come do you still
dance when you're sad or you're stressed
do you still
dance it out no not so much anymore not
since christina left
christina didn't i know
that's what i miss about being alive
dancing until you drop
laughing till you cry
you